Google Cloud updates we've recently
published the inaugural state of
kubernetes cost optimization report to
provide insights and best practices to
the kubernetes community about running
cost-efficient clusters in the public
Cloud without compromising the
performance or reliability of their
workloads you can read about it on the
blog or join us August 9th on Twitter
spaces to learn more multitasking can be
kind of tricky to execute and the same
principles can apply to executing
parallel workflows but thankfully for
Google workflows and our new guide you
can use a parent workflow to set up and
execute parallel child workflows the
step-by-step guide will show you how to
implement parallel execution of
workflows and combine the results using
Google Cloud workflows plus there's a
video so check out the links below for
everything that we've covered on this
week's